ok look what he has
never all say make sure you did
basically something that just religion
disquiet car sounds like no yoga
in school I gotta take a step ahead and
then chest I got yourself in hangover if
I know that we have an attested certain
days I got a stud so may see they're
like thinking a step for him
I really think it just gets kids a
chance to stop and think you know
they're then they're gonna make a move
and there's gonna be consequences from
the next move that obviously is what
chess is but it applies I'll be on out
to life in London dad I'm me out oh yeah
welcome to San Luis language immersion
school we've got a good group of
students here we actually run eight
classes a week here and this is the
kindergarten class they can fully set up
the chess board and actually play I'm
impressed with the progress of the
entire scholastic store we've got about
a thousand kids just this fall and after
six to eight weeks of programming every
single student knows how to play chess
and is ready and able to compute okay I
know it's gonna look that good chess is
the best thing I ever went to I like to
play chess and the best value piece to
me is the Queen's castle a rope it puts
you forward and lies
you